mainframes what about Microsoft cloud
mainframes are critical to your business
they're secure reliable and scalable for
all your most important applications in
data to continue to build on this
investment businesses are looking to
extend core applications in a hybrid
Cloud Model as part of Microsoft cloud I
agree that's a smart strategy right by
introducing your Mainframe developers to
Microsoft cloud you're leveraging modern
tools and removing silos in your
development process hi I'm Brian Lang
from IBM and I'm Shelby Howard from
Microsoft today we're going to explain
how we're partnering to bring the
strengths of both IBM Z and Microsoft
cloud to our clients ready you bet so
we're already working together by
delivering ibmc and the cloud
modernization stack through Azure
Marketplace let's walk through a
realistic problem that our partnership
can solve yeah so imagine a scenario
where a client is a manufacturing client
they have
dealerships referencing their part
systems but their supply chain issues so
those dealerships are actually hitting
the IBM Z looking for parts as they come
in uh because there's a shortage and
they're really hammering the Mainframe
to get that imature so the ibmc is
really overworked in terms of
consumption it's really delivering a
bunch of non update transactions yeah
and and so there's potentially a need
for additional capacity but to solve a
short-term issue because it's ideally
not a long-term issue with supply chain
so how do we how do we help this
customer uh solve the problem so we're
able to add agility by creating an API
in Azure and directing that traffic to
Azure and this update happens as the
inventory is replenished so we're timing
the update through the API and um
leveraging Azure API management okay so
now we have an API that's running in the
Microsoft cloud and it's basically
servicing all of the query traffic
that's coming from those dealers without
impacting the ibmc the ibmc really gets
to sit back and relax yeah EX exactly so
we're we're getting the value that the
dealerships need being able to um
purchase that inventory as it comes up
but um but we're not driving that
consumption on the main frame and the
ibmc is not really sitting back and
relaxing it's driving a bunch of
transactions and obviously one of those
transactions is going to be when that
inventory gets updated it now updates
the API feeding the dealership but it's
a purposeful transaction absolutely so
now that we've got uh our client
developed uh developing code in the
Microsoft cloud with the mod stack
they've got an API maybe they've
expanded that to to do multiple apis um
you know take us through how they how
they start that process how did how do
they get there yeah so the design and
develop is actually happening in Azure
um leveraging the mod stack okay so I've
got a developer uh interacting with the
mod stack running in the Microsoft cloud
um I've designed I've developed it
what's the next step well next step is
going to be to deploy the API okay so
now I've got got that API running in the
Microsoft cloud again servicing in
between the IBM z uh and whatever the
end user may be in this case our
dealership um but really how does
anybody even know that that API has been
developed so the next step is to expose
the API but you've deployed the API of
runtime in Azure um and also one thing
to mention here is that the API is
leveraging um open API 3 standards okay
so the only really the only reason why
we've been able to integrate these
things between Microsoft cloud and ibmc
is because we're all supporting open
industry standards so now we're going to
expose that API correct yes and you're
exposing it leveraging Azure API
management um and that gives you
consistency across your environment
managing all of your apis okay so who
are we exposing it to obviously we're
exposing it to the dealerships in this
example so that they're updating their
code make sure that they're accessing
the API as OPP post to ibmc directly who
else might want access to that API
that's a good point so we've solved the
problem here by exposing the API for
this scenario um but that API can also
be leveraged uh for new capability and
let's say the client wants to um create
a power app using low code no code um
they could also leverage that API in the
future okay so now we're extending that
ability we're taking the taking the
investment that a client's had in modack
and in Microsoft cloud extending the
value of ibmc not only for this for this
problem and solving this problem but now
solving multiple problems and expanding
the expanding that value into other uh
other Realms really um what other use
cases do we have that uh that we can
talk about with our clients yeah um so
we we're talking about apis one of the
other things to mention about Azure API
management is that you also have the
ability to deploy security policies
using that and control traffic so having
that consistency is key for development
across the Enterprise um the next thing
is actually Dev Ops so um expanding on
development uh we can bring the
Mainframe development into Azure
leveraging the the mod stack um and
create um new capability there too so so
mod stack supports both modern languages
we're talking Java go node.js but also
Cobalt right so you can update your zos
applications using mod stack with your
developers running in Microsoft cloud
yes and going back to uh the example
where we have an API that's exposed
um to maybe a new application in Azure
um you also are removing barriers across
scrum teams by having Cloud native
development being done in other areas as
well as through the Mainframe team and
again because it's open industry
standards tied in with Azure devops open
industry standards that code can be
written there the code can be developed
there and then the application can be
deployed back to ibmc and running on the
on the main frame yeah and one of the
other important things is that you have
testing that happens end to- end testing
in Azure um leveraging a wasi Sandbox
yeah so unit testing on there you're
obviously going to bring that back and
do your integration and production level
testing back on IBM z uh fantastic any
other use cases that we have yes so one
other use case that we have is um
optimizing storage so when we look at
this we're talking about optimizing tape
storage or dis storage by leveraging
ashure blob storage and and directing
that storage into Azure okay so in that
case you really taking an alternative
approach to to putting some cold storage
into the Microsoft cloud obviously if
you need to do any kind of analytics or
any kind of data update to that you
actually have to bring that that data
back to the back to the Mainframe to
actually do transaction processing
against it yes the use case is dis
optimization but you also have the
ability to have an additional or
redundant storage copy if maybe it's a
regulatory requirement great so these
are the three patterns that we've
already delivered they're already
available in the Microsoft Cloud looking
forward to expanding that partnership as
we solve more problems for our customers
I'll give you the last word thank you so
uh we we have um a lot of our clients
investing in both the ibmc and Microsoft
cloud and we walk through an example
scenario today where we were solving a
problem for a client uh we can also help
you solve a real world example for your
environment and not only just solving a
problem one of the things that I would
encourage is that you look uh for
additional capability outside of just
solving a problem now knowing that the
two platforms can interact a lot more
closely there may be a different way to
look at your environment and adding
additional value to your business thanks
for watching before you leave don't
forget to hit like And
subscribe